chuckle I got a question regarding the
quote if there is a doubt there's no
doubt alright remember that yeah the
last time okay this would seem to
indicate avoiding taking risks many many
businesses or many business decisions
involve risk often there can be a doubt
about either of two options doubt that
you should maintain the status quo and
doubt about pursuing a new opportunity
to frequent or you frequently talk about
dichotomies would you mind sharing your
thoughts on this principle yeah this is
this is a classic thing and and it's a
great point and that's why these little
sound bites can be a little bit
dangerous sometimes a little power sound
bites because they are that simple and
of course I love I like things to be
simple right that's the number two law
of combat is to keep things simple but
sometimes things like this need a little
bit of amplifying information and yes
this could be construed as being
extremely risk-averse and like hey if I
have any doubt about the safety of
success of this mission that we're not
gonna do it which if that was the case
then I would have done a zero missions
during my deployments to Iraq same with
business never would have started
victory MMA never would have started
echelon front because there was risk
involved in starting those things never
would have done anything really because
there's always gonna be done so this is
a accurate statement and of course every
business has risk and so so I guess that
idea that if there is a doubt there is
no doubt it's not to be taken literally
when it comes to risk when it comes to
risk don't take it literally but what it
should be I think is like a a warning
right like a little warning that's in
your head if there's a doubt like okay
we need to think about what's going on
here we need to understand what what is
at risk here because and I just had this
conversation with the CEO of a company
as a matter of fact let's talk about
that I caught me of leadership I was
talking about how you know giving him
examples like for instance in and he was
in a technology company and I said you
know if you didn't take risk you
wouldn't you wouldn't make any progress
but if you took too much risk you
wouldn't be where you are right now
because they're dominating so it's like
oh you're you're balancing that
dichotomy all the time so if you would
have said hey if there was a doubt there
is no doubt you never would have gotten
off the ground now where I think it
becomes a more solid statement is from
like a moral or an ethical standpoint
and that is if you think that something
is wrong all that it probably is think
you're doing something that you probably
shouldn't be doing then there's doubt
and you probably shouldn't be doing it I
think an easy way to keep yourself in
check and these days it's a very real
possibility is just if you think that
you're being recorded at all times like
if you just think oh I'm being recorded
which probably somebody is recording you
yeah like if you decide you think you
can get away with something you're
probably not gonna get away with it look
at all the just go watch YouTube you're
the caught in the act or whatever people
need call all the time so whatever
you're doing think that there could be
somebody there with a phone recording
you and I think that's keeps you a
morally and ethically in check you know
I used to tell my guys that you could be
getting watched by CNN or Al Jazeera or
some reporter you know whoever you you
know you could be getting watched and if
you're doing something that you
shouldn't be doing you're you're gonna
get caught so don't do it not to mention
these days we got the aircraft overhead
they can see everything so do with the
right thing mmm that's what you do you
do the right thing yeah
if you have any doubt that what you're
doing is the right thing then you should
probably shouldn't do it
a lot of those a lot of the horrible
police actions yeah are you know
recorded by some random person with the
phone now of course I always need to
point out that there's all these good
actions that take place every single day
millions and millions of police do the
right thing yeah no one publishes those
no one uploads those onto YouTube or
Facebook but the bad acts that are
caught they're caught because someone
has a camera yeah and so like that's
great advice for a cop hey act like
you're being recorded all the time yeah
yeah it's yeah that's interesting well
it makes me very well might be yeah yeah
so do the right thing
next question thank God I didn't have
cameras when I was a kid for all the
dumb stuff I did yeah yeah oh I always
want to make sure that I'm not sitting
here saying like I everyone out there
should do the right thing like me yeah
yeah I'm not saying that if you thought
I was saying that I'm not saying that I
apologize for even sounding them like I
was as dumb and stupid as the next
person and still do dumb stuff try not
to even man you don't do dumb stuff
right no it was bad when when when we
had Charlie plum and Jim Conklin yeah
and I'm like thinking they're like you
know hey this is the way to act right
I'm like don't put me with you guys you
guys are awesome heroes and I'm just
over here yeah yeah don't say that about
me you guys can say like a talk about
character you have character I'm just
over here yeah